l'essayiste et ancien ambassadeur michel
raimbault michel raimbault bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur arte
france réouverture des frontières
terrestres et levée du boycott donc les
frontières aériennes devraient rouvrir
demain une première étape dans la
réconciliation bien la réconciliation
est-elle déjà acté je pense que l'accord
de la réconciliation déjà joué à acter
oui de toute façon elle va ceci n'est
pas achevé et va s'achever bientôt
en réalité j'étais assez important mais
c'est pas si surprenante ça parce que je
n'ai pas quand même le boycott la sortie
du qatar de la conseil de coopération du
golfe
par exemple c'est quand même un
événement qui a eu lieu il ya trois ans
et quelques je crois que quelques années
c'est pas grand chose et le fait que les
révélations sur établi pour bien qu'il
n'y avait pas de différentes formes
parce que la situation
finalement quel changé je ne sais pas je
crois que ce qui a changé en réalité
vaudois aux idées du point de vue du
leucate à une part c'est vrai ça dure ça
nous enlève une épine du pied puisque
c'est la seule frontière
il peut avoir intérêt à l'opéra qui se
déprécie paiement et donc ils voulaient
ils étaient coincés en quelque sorte
dans ce qui est et nationales à peine au
dessus du qatar alors en même temps je
crois que l'espace aérien a été
réouverte qu'effrontées en faire une
vraie donc no kata n'est plus vraiment
de soleil il ne dépareront gagneur il
avait quand tout ça frontières salon
entièrement iphone du rivage est
tellement le seul visage qui n'avait
c'était un peu gênant pour les saoudiens
pour les pays du golfe c'est délirant
or l'entretien est ce qui a poussé rien
des doigts à renouer les liens il ya
trois ans et demi il y avait justement
des divergences au niveau de l'iran au
sujet des frères musulmans
y avait il y avait les deux pas des fois
on a pris quelqu'un on a parfois dit que
le qatar est une oeuvre représentant des
soutes et l'islam politique n'était pas
le seul en oublie quand même que dans
les dix dernières années dans les
printemps arabes
que gagne deux ailes du mouvement
islamiste et du mouvement et du soutien
aux terroristes
il y avait sept
musulmans effectivement la turquie et le
qatar donc avec cette alliance
et puis d'autre part il y avait quand
même là l'arabie saoudite et les émirats
qui soutenaient la les courants où
j'habite dans quel pin ou tel courant
wahhabite qui a soutenu aussi activement
le nouveau notre courant disons le
mouvement des périodes et janis et mitch
nato et est en révolution syrienne par
exemple et donc c'était finalement mais
dans la réalité sur le terrain qu'ils
savaient d'assez bon ménage
et quand même il y avait une
concertation de qatari copie el arabi
qu'on se rappelle les secrets 20 km de
polichinelle qui avait été dévoilée par
l'ancien premier ministre et homme fort
du qatar dans toutes les télés pétition
en arabie saoudite il a encore donné il
faut accepter coordonnées des de
financer mais peu en pectine et celle du
qatar ont joué un rôle sur le terrain
mais qu'est ce qui va changer alors
pourquoi est ce que aujourd'hui les
liens sont rétablis qu'est ce qui a
changé par rapport à il ya trois ans et
demi pourquoi aujourd'hui pro maintenant
je pense vox est liée à la l'iran en
réalité c'est lié à la fin du mandat
troublée de trump il ya finalement la
même dégradation de la situation dans la
région notamment vis-à-vis de l'iran qui
a fait suite disons aux décisions des
preuves dernière ces sanctions
l'assassinât de m on est à un an après
l'assassinât du général
sulejmani général iranien et son
collègue se limite je pense que
finalement ce le l'iran est l'objet
d'une sanction est l'objet de menaces de
delà des pays du golfe dont l'arabie
saoudite notamment qui concerne tous les
pays du golfe dont considère que depuis
un an l'iran est devenu l'ennemi des
arabes est l'ennemi des pays de la
région
est ce qui est une nouveauté ça me sera
est donc celle de l'iran et est en
conséquence alors au niveau
international à la fois géopolitiquement
quelles conséquences alors au niveau
international d'un point de vue
géopolitique de sa ré ouvre je pense là
mais le qatar
effectivement ça lui en donne une fine
oxygène sarr nous disons à lui le nul ça
remet à l'ordre du jour l'unité au sein
du conseil de coopération du golfe
on se rappellera compte que le conseil
de coopération du golfe que
l'instabilité créée c'était pour lutter
contre l'iran c'était ça son seul but en
réalité et donc il y avait une anomalie
qui est réparé au moins pour l'instant
je connais l'avenir parce que disons si
tous les trois ans les situations
changent pour l'instant je crois qu'il
s'agit de faire front contre l'iran
puisque vu du point de vue de l'art
habitants des émirats des halles danger
majeur voire même de l'egypte alors un
hôte le kata est obligé de garder bonne
relâche qui avec l'iran parce que d'une
part c'est son vis-à-vis et la mer du
nord du golfe de trois heures
mais par contre les gars les qatari les
gisements gaz du qatar c'est un grand
producteur de gaz l'iran également
et pourquoi une dernière les gisements
de gaz de connaissent pas de frontières
même maritime et par conséquent il y
aura une certaine concertation ils ne
peuvent pas avoir de mauvaises relations
disons en trop mauvaise mais en réalité
ne vais rien à ceux du qatar
on n'était pas très très mauvaise il y
avait quand même un minimum était
maintenu on était au grand désespoir de
l'arabie saoudite ce désespoir est réglé
alors après je ne sais pas je pense que
l'iran finalement dit non nous on
entendra cette situation là mais ça
change un petit peu le psy que
logiquement je pense qu'elle doit mettre
à l'aise des saoudiens et émiratis
essart établis ou un nominalement unités
de la cci du conseil de l'opérateur du
bol face à l'iran avec ses adversaires
qu'avaient été désignés dont il ya
maintenant près de 40 près de près de 40
ans quand le conseil a été formé merci
merci michel raimbault à d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes ancien ambassadeur de france est
essayiste spécialiste des relations
internationales